the Crowds Are Back waiting to board
this freight train known as La Bestia or
the Beast
some are running again after being
stopped following the deaths of several
migrants
people have been killed trying to board
moving trains and others after falling
from them
but that hasn't stopped many from trying
we are going to continue on our journey
and in fact we're waiting for a train
I've heard there have been accidents but
not as many as people say you have to be
careful and get on a train when it
stopped not when it's moving
Mexico's rail network is used by many to
travel the 3 000 kilometer Journey from
Mexico south to North
we've been walking for nine to ten days
walking is awful because in my group we
have people whose feet are injured mine
too and with such a long way to go until
we reached the U.S border I don't think
we can make it by walking
activists are pushing for rail
operations to return to normal as they
say migrants are left with little option
but to walk
we have to understand that this is the
only means of travel they have they
aren't allowed to buy bus tickets and if
they do it's done in secret these are
very vulnerable people who face great
Danger
in May the number of migrants initially
dropped when new Asylum restrictions
were introduced the changes disqualified
those applying for Asylum who haven't
crossed through an official Port of
Entry nor applied for legal protection
in another safe country on their journey
to America the latest U.S government
data shows the number being detained
along the U.S Mexico border Rising by
more than 30 percent with those trying
to make this dangerous Journey likely to
increase
Mike level of Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera